"John Wick: Chapter 4" might just be the biggest
and best "Wick" yet, but as the old saying goes,
you can't make an epic action movie with cutting
some heads open. We'll let Keanu Reeves explain.
The "John Wick" franchise has been
praised for its use of practical effects
and immaculate stunt-work, always pushing
the boundaries of what audiences expect,
with each entry being bigger,
bolder, and arguably better.
Naturally, this makes the production of the movies
a highly choreographed affair behind the scenes,
on account of the intense moments of
hand-to-hand combat, snappy gunplay,
and jaw-dropping stunts. Unfortunately, accidents
do happen, and it seems as if Keanu Reeves himself
is responsible for injuring a co-worker during
the production of "John Wick: Chapter 4."
During an interview with ComicBook.com,
Reeves was asked about the number of
accidents that occur during the
filming of a "John Wick" movie,
and he prefaced his answer by describing
the conditions on set. Reeves said,
"Everyone is pretty tired, but it's the best
kind of tired. It's like you climbed a mountain,
now you're resting; like you
finished the game and you won."
Reeves then mentioned two on-set accidents
that sent stunt performers to the hospital:
"In terms of accidents, I made a mistake
once and I cut a gentleman's head open. So
that really f-----g sucked. Excuse my language."
The other incident involved one of the
film's many car-based stunts. Reeves added,
"One guy got hit by a car. He was in the car, so
he had to go to the hospital, but he was okay."
Reeves didn't provide any context to
the circumstances of either incident,
and considering the nature
of the "John Wick" movies,
it could have been anybody in "Chapter
4" who happens to come up against the
fearsome killer. And "Chapter 4" is filled
to the brim with chaotic vehicular action.
In an interview with Digital Trends, stunt
coordinators Scott Rogers and Stephen Dunlevy
opened up about how difficult it was to film
the Paris Arc de Triomphe sequence because
of the amount of people that needed
to get hit with cars. Rogers said,
"[We] had to figure out how many people can you
hit with cars without taking each one
of them to the hospital. We want to
do these spectacular stunts but without
losing sight of the reality of it all."
Safety is critical to making
these action sequences work,
and Reeves told Comicbook.com that the "John
Wick" team really cares for one another, adding,
"All of this is to say, some of the stuff
that we're doing, you do have to take care.
It's great that everyone is
watching out for each other."
Considering that there are 98 people
credited for stunts on "Chapter 4,"
it seems like the movie had a veritable
army of those willing to fight, shoot,
and get hit for the sake of cinematic glory,
despite the risk of accidents. Then again,
making something great is hardly ever
easy or without the occasional misstep.
Those in the stunt industry love working on
the "John Wick" flicks as much as audiences
enjoy watching them. Continuing his chat with
Digital Trends, "Chapter 4" stunt coordinator
Stephen Dunlevy described the franchise as "the
pinnacle of the stunt industry" and revealed
that he turned down other films to work on the
latest offering from director Chad Stahelski.
Despite the injuries that manifested on
the film's set, it's clear that the "John
Wick" films value personal safety and
pushing the boundaries of stunt work.
As it stands, "John Wick: Chapter 4"
is the most critically-acclaimed film
in the franchise, with many
claiming it's one of the best
action films ever put to screen.
Clearly, hard work does pay off.